okay here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna play a three minute game
and I'm gonna play a gamut
and regardless of what happens in this
game
it's gonna go on YouTube
so shout out to people in the future
watching on YouTube
and shout out to people in the present
watching on Twitch
also things for southern hi YouTube yeah
Budapest Canada time just for YouTube
if you're watching on YouTube in the
future you can watch another episode
please and
if you have Amazon Prime you can
subscribe on Twitch does really help
support the channel
here we go okay so I'm playing a
Budapest which
I actually have a lot of YouTube videos
on there's a cool idea to Rook lift
um play this and then Castle
idea rookie Eights
okay I'm gonna mute alerts for the rest
of the game
sometimes people in YouTube comments
complain
but uh yeah I'm gonna go through with
this plan of Rook A6 Rook H6
and
yeah we're staying with the Gambit Vibes
of playing Ultra Ultra aggressively
can I get out of this Pawn
so Rook H6 takes Queen H4 H3 D6 there's
Rook A8
I think I'll take first
okay change the plans I'm gonna play
very positionally
D6 B6 I want to Target this Pawn on C4
sometimes this happens when you play a
Gambit is you have to
kind of switch gears
and do what the position calls for
I actually like the setup
the pawns are smiling this Pawn's
attacked
and pawns are smiling at this Pawn's
loominess
I think I can take and then Queen C5
rookie one almost chops a queen
wow I've worked B8
can't take the queen oh I have this move
too
creating a a nice configuration
this Bishops tie down to G2
uh neither five might be coming
it'd be okay though because I have
Knight F6
okay time's about level here oh I don't
have 906
I pawn F6
always play off six
actually it looks okay
maybe these pawns will smile too
wow
so takes takes Rook B8
got into it
down a little bit of time
a knight C5 that over defends the bishop
and prepares rookie eight
wow
I mean this looks like another Free Pawn
Bishop C4 probably coming
and then King f8
and then Rook a three and then G6
how to do this
I could play King h82
ah there's a cool idea
actually wait there's also Rook A1 here
oh maybe I'll just play this and this
the G7 hangs
I feel more pressure I feel like I have
to deliver for the YouTube audience
takes
I also Gotta Move more quickly
King E7
ready to take the pawn maybe ready to
play this move
not ready to take the pawn
okay so I'm up a lot of puns of three
Pawns
okay past ones must be pushed
the king F6 and King E5
uh did this move
and doing some fun maneuvering
there we go
okay
where's my funny mate
can I get a Rosen trophy I can get a
windmill
where's my funny mate
[Music]
ah it's made in three
yeah
hey it's a nice little cube mate
a very Diversified cube of pieces
okay I hope people enjoy that on Twitch
and on YouTube
uh thanks for watching
if you want to learn more about the
Budapest candidates
uh I think I have a playlist actually if
I don't have a playlist I'll make a
playlist of all my Budapest videos
so be sure to check that out and
subscribe if you want to see more
content and stay tuned for the next
video